-Welcome back.
-Thank you for having me.
-I think this is
a very exciting time to have you
less than a week
before midterm elections.
You've been out
promoting this film.
You've been urging people
to vote.
-Yes, yes.
And I've been working
for candidates and,
at the same time,
yes, the film is out.
Actually, I had to go to Europe
to open it over there.
Get back here
to help the election.
And I've been
so busy, actually --
I'm gonna be on the road
next weekend.
I won't be home
in Michigan to vote,
and my absentee ballot
just arrived
just before I came down here.
And so, if you don't mind,
could I just vote?
-Yeah, do you want to vote
right now?
You want to show people
how easy it is to vote?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is the actual --
the actual ballot
for the state of Michigan.
Thank you very much.
-And have you done --
You've done all your research?
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
-Okay.
-And I -- I know everybody
on this ballot.
-You know everybody, yes.
-So, uh, I'm gonna vote for
Gretchen there for governor.
-Uh-huh.
-And, you know,
there are so many women
on the ballot.
You'll notice this
when you go to vote next week.
Just teachers alone,
there are 550 teachers
across the country
that are running
for state house or state rep.
-That's really exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It'S an amazing --
While you're voting,
I want to say that you --
One of the things
you talk about in the film
is how the biggest block of
voters are those who don't vote.
More people didn't vote
than voted for either
of the candidates.
-It's our largest political
party, the non-voters.
Sad -- Sad to say.
-So how do you encourage those?
What is the message
you give to the non-voters
to get them out the door
this coming Tuesday?
-The thing I -- The thing
I say to non-voters is,
actually, I don't think
it works to, like, shame them
or wag your finger at them.
I think you should
listen to them
and find out
why they're not voting.
I'm guessing most people
that don't vote, that stay home,
do it because they're just --
they've given up,
the system has failed them.
They don't see any difference
between the candidates.
It's the same old hacks running.
And so, they stay home.
But I'm gonna guess that
the majority of non-voters
deeply love their country
and are deeply patriotic.
And it's got to be
very hard for them, Seth,
to stay home
and not participate.
And I think
they'd love to participate.
And so what I say to them
this year is,
there are so many people
on the ballot this time
that are not the party hacks.
I mean, there's a --
There's a woman running
for Congress in West Virginia,
who she's a chicken farmer.
There's a bus driver,
I think it's in Kentucky,
that's running.
There's a librarian where I live
I mean, these are, like --
You know, there's a lunch lady
that's running somewhere
out in the Northwest,
that's running for office.
I mean, like, normal people
are running this time.
A lot of them are women.
A lot of them are young people.
And I think my -- if any
non-voter is watching this,
I'd say give it a shot
just this one time.
Show up just this one time.
I think you'll be surprised
by who's on the ballot.
And we can throw
all the bastards out.
-There you go.
-That's why --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now --
-Oh.
Prop 1 in Michigan.
-Yeah.
-Legalizing marijuana.
-Oh, are you on the fence
on this one?
-No, do you want to help me
fill this one in?
-It looks like
it came filled in.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-The band
wanted to vote on this.
[ Laughter ]
No, no.
This is all my voting.
Only I have touched this ballot.
-All right, good.
-'Cause they're watching
in Michigan, and they'll --
-Yeah.
-There we go.
Thank you for letting me vote.
-So I want to ask about this.
You were here right before
the 2016 election.
And you --
Because, again, there's
this predicted blue wave.
You were very cautious
going into the election.
You actually believed that
Donald Trump was gonna win.
You called it --
You called it state by state.
So now
I'm give you another chance --
how do you feel about Tuesday?
-Well, I'm not gonna make the
mistake that someone else made
on a late-night show
a couple nights ago.
-Okay.
-A Democrat.
-Yes.
-Who just automatically
announced, "We're gonna win."
-Uh-huh.
-And it's like,
"My God, that's what happened
in 2016."
Everybody was throwing the party
for Hillary before the election.
And I think
some people stayed home.
I think some people
didn't think it was --
Like, everybody said --
Even "The New York Times"
on election day in 2016
in that box
where they predict...
-Yeah.
-...said that there was only
a "15% chance today"
of Trump winning the presidency.
-Right.
-Okay.
So you got to throw
all that out.
You got to quit this kind of
predicting nonsense,
and you just got to
do your job as a citizen.
Everybody's got to get off
the bench this time.
We may not get another time.
He's actually talked about,
you know,
"Well, you know, maybe we'll
have to postpone an election
because there's these --"
I can't do
the voice that you do.
-No, you're doing great.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
This is -- This --
[ Laughter ]
-By the way, you're like the
only person who can't do Trump.
-Right?
This is you with a cold.
-Okay, yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
-But it's -- it's --
People have to --
look, I think, obviously,
one of two things can happen.
And I heard Steve Bannon
lay out his blueprint
of how they think
they're going to win on Tuesday.
And they think they're gonna
keep the House by one seat.
And anybody
who doesn't trust that,
please remember that
Donald Trump outsmarted us.
He outsmarted us in 2016
and won the White House
by losing the election.
That takes a certain kind of
evil genius to figure that out.
So don't think for a second
that, come Tuesday,
they don't have every intention
of holding on to the House
and the Senate.
And they are good
at what they do.
And you should respect the fact
that they are able
to get away with this.
They got away with it
with Gore when he won.
We didn't do anything about it.
They got away with it
when Hillary won.
We don't do anything about it.
They know us.
-Yeah.
-They know we're busy,
and we got other things to do.
-[ Laughs ]
-But they are fanatical
about this
because they know
their time is up.
And sort of the --
the "angry white guy,"
which, actually,
I'm really Trump's demographic.
-Yeah. You're a Michigan
angry white guy.
-I'm an angry white guy over 50
with a high school education.
[ Laughter ]
So that's me.
-Yeah.
-So if I could just speak
to my fellow angry white
American guys
who are semi-uneducated
like me...
[ Laughter ]
Dudes, give it up!
We've been running the show
for 10,000 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like --
It's like, we've had a long run
as men running everything.
And, you know, the Yankees
could never win as many pennants
as we've won
in these 10,000 years as men.
-Right.
-So why don't we just
take a break?
Let the majority gender
run the show.
-Just for -- yeah.
Just to see how it would go.
-What are you scared of?
Women actually like us.
[ Laughter ]
Most of us.
You know?
So -- So I just think
there's just this --
Trump is in there
trying to whip up,
as you were showing earlier,
that all that fear
and all that
"Here come the hordes,"
and doing this and that...
It's like, you know, people --
Hopefully, people have not
fallen for it, not the majority.
The majority are with us.
The majority believe
in the liberal agenda.
Every poll shows this, Seth.
Whether it's climate change,
equal pay for women,
raising the minimum wage,
the majority of Americans
agree with all those things
should happen,
and we've got to trust that
and start to feel that
we have the power, but we have
to exercise it on Tuesday.
And you got
to get five people --
Everyone in here knows five
people that doesn't vote.
And we've got to get --
bring five people
to the polls with you.
Have a party afterwards.
Bring beer.
Do whatever you've got to do,
but let's pack
those polling places on Tuesday.